how do you buy a house through a limited
company and should you buy a house to a
company or should you just buy a house
without the need of a company well in my
opinion you should absolutely have a
company even if you haven't got a house
yet even if you're like looking around
you don't know what house you're going
to buy having a limited company is going
to help you
massively you might not even understand
how it's going to help you right now but
man you want to watch this video till
the end because i'm going to be hitting
you with some dynamite so here goes when
you have a company you can claim stuff
back as tax deductible this is huge
right now if you're an employee
you're still paying for stuff you're
still paying for a mobile phone you're
still paying for rent
do you know if you're in business you
can claim back part of your rent as long
as you can demonstrate that you're using
your house for office as well
this is not my dining room table this is
my boardroom table i'm claiming this
part of the house back tax deductible
does this make sense
right now if you're an employer you're
not claiming anything back
you are getting paid i don't know two
grand
firstly you're paying your tax first but
when you have a limited company you pay
your tax last oh it's so good what do i
mean by that i mean um if you get paid
two grand you're not gonna see that two
grand you're only going to see 1 600
because first they're going to take off
your pay ay tax your national insurance
you're going to be left with just 1600.
that's not how it works when you have a
company when you have a company you pay
tax last
you should definitely be buying
properties through a company i didn't
used to teach this i didn't used to do
this but they changed the rules they
brought in all these new legislation and
they're taxing the crap out of poor
people
working class people amateur landlords
amateur landlords are getting squeezed
for every penny whereas the big
companies and the elites
they're they're fine they don't pay
taxes hardly why because they're doing
it through companies they're not buying
individually you can do the same thing
too they changed the rules you didn't
used to be able to this is why this is
so groundbreaking if you used to want to
set a company up and buy a house with a
company they'd say no they're going no
you can't just set up a company and buy
a house
because you can't buy a house to a
limited company unless you can prove
that it's got so many years books
we want to see the profit we want to see
the turnover the sustainability of the
business now in 2022
many people don't know this
you can set up a brand spanking new
company today
and then tomorrow
you can buy a house through that company
no questions asked how do you do it
through personal guarantor you will get
you will be the guarantor to the company
but you'll get all the tax benefits
of owning it through the company section
24 tax won't exist
you won't pay capital gains tax when you
sell you'll pay corporation tax which is
way cheaper you when you get paid your
rent
you won't pay any tax on the first 12
000 pounds nothing no tax
and then thereafter you'll pay yourself
in a dividend and only pay seven and a
half percent tax right up into 40
something thousand pounds this is
crazy
crazy cheap tax-wise compared to if you
just bought a house
so how do you set up a limited company
here's what you do you go to a website
called companies made simple
and then you type in what you want your
company to be called and i would suggest
don't overthink this just put your name
followed by property limited whatever if
that company name is still available
you then just press submit you go
through a few pages fill some details
out
this takes like 20 minutes and within 24
hours you will have your own limited
company
and you will have a company number and
it will cost you about 12 pounds
crazy it's i don't know why i teach this
stuff in school it does my heading
really doesn't headed once you've got
your company set up
let's say you've got a company called
purple rain property limited right
you've got your company then when you
view all the houses that you're viewing
with an estate agent you say hey i'd
like to put forward an offer of 200 and
they'll say offer accepted you'll say
just say you know it's not me buying it
it's my company purple rain property
limited and they go okay cool don't make
any difference then when you get a
solicitor on board you'll tell the
solicitor i'm buying this property
through this company you'll tell your
your broker it's just a company now
what are the downsides to buying through
a company um you might pay a slightly
higher interest rate if you're buying
through a company you will also probably
need to have an accountant which you're
going to obviously have to pay because
if you don't have an accountant you do
it yourself it could be a little bit so
again that's a small downside but the
plus sides are absolutely huge the thing
you really need to do is you just need
to get educated because this is i mean
when you when you don't have a company
this is the big this is this is just
huge
when you pay a bunch of tax first and
then you just spend what's left
and then you spend on rent and your car
and your holidays what are you left with
probably nothing
so you've got zero profit
whereas if you have a company what how
does it work well if you have a company
firstly let's say you're paying yourself
two grand a month
okay or or 30 grand a year if you're
paying yourself from your company 30
grand a year
or if that's how much profit the company
is making
you're gonna you're gonna squeeze the
profit down on normal expenses like your
mobile phone
okay
this is not my mobile phone this is my
business mobile phone
so i'm able to claim
the expense of it back
so when you have a company you can start
claiming stuff back which means you can
offset that against the taxes and end up
paying no tax because if you've got no
profit in the business technically no
profit then you'll pay no tax listen i'm
not a tax expert so i'm not qualified to
teach or give tax advice
but
get clued up on this okay if you want to
do more videos on tax i can do if you
want to pull my accountant in and do an
interview with him i can do get clued up
on tax see you next time
[Music]
you